اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في تطورات المتسارعه
للمحاوله الفاشله لاغتيال الرئيس الروسي
عبر طائره اوكرانيه مسيره استهدفت
الكرملين ليلا وهو ما نفته الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه واكدت انها على علم بان الهجوم
على قد يتسبب في رد فعل روسي متطرف
مشاهدينا يمكنكم متابعه تطورات الاقتتال
في السودان عبر شاشه الحدث
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا اتهمت روسيا اوكرانيا بانها
حاولت مهاجمه
واعلنت الرئاسه الروسيه اسقاط طائرتين
مسيرتين حاولت استهداف مقر الرئاسه
الروسيه اضاف الكيلاني ان روسيا سترد على
محاوله الهجوم الاوكرانيه في الوقت
والمكان المناسبين في وقت لاحق اعلن عده
موسكو
اعلن حظر استخدام اي طائرات مدنيه غير
مصرح لها في العاصمه
وقال المتحدث باسم كريم
مع الامم المتحده والاطراف الاخرى في صفقه
الحبوب في البحر الاسود وان موسكو لن تفعل
اي شيء اي شيء يضر بمصالحها
الامور الاتصالات بين الاطراف تسير بشكل
منطقي الجانب الروسي سيوصل الاتصال بكل من
الامم المتحده والممثلين الاخرين على امل
ان يتم الوفاء بشروط الاتفاق بعد كل شيء
وبالطبع لن تفعل روسيا اي شيء يتعارض مع
مصالحها
وبدايه كيف يتفاعل هذا الملف في الداخل
الروسي وما ابرز ضد الفعل المرصوده حتى
اللحظه
مرحبا احمد بالفعل هذا الهجوم الذي تم
تنفيذه على الكرملين وكما تحدث
ان هذه المسيرات هي تابعه للجانب
الاوكراني وهو هجوم اوكراني كان يستهدف
الرئيس الروسي واغتيال الرئيس الروسي
الذي طبعا كما قال انه لم يكن متواجدا
لحظه حدوث هذا الهجوم هو هذا الهجوم طبعا
كما يعتبره الخبراء وكما تعتبرته تحدثت
عنه بعض وسائل الاعلام الروسيه ياتي بعد
تاكيدات كانت خرجت من الغرب عدم حول عدم
استخدام اوكرانيا للاسلحه التي تقوم
بتزويدها بها
لاستخدامها ضد الاراسي الاراضي الروسيه او
داخل الاراضي الروسيه طبعا هذا ما تعتبره
طبعا روسيا بمثابه انتهاك باراضيها وكما
قال بيسكوف اليوم انه هذا الهجوم سيكون
طبعا له رد تختاره روسيا طريقه تنفيذه
تنفيذ سيكون طبعا من الجانب الروسي ردا
على هذا الانتهاك الكبير لانه طبعا هذا
الهجوم هو
اول هجوم يخترق العاصمه الروسيه وقلب
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو يصل الى قلب الكريم
كما شاهدت او تناول تناولت وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه لصور كان هناك حريق نشب على سطح
الكريم لربما هو طبعا نتيجه تفجير المسيره
التي سقطت على سطح الكريم بالاضافه الى
ذلك كان قد تحدث طبعا
هذا العمل هو عمل ارهابي كان يستهدف
الرئيس
الروسيا قبيل بدايه احتفالات عيد النصر
التي ستجري خلال الايام المقبله طبعا هو
هجوم هذا هو احد الهجوم الذي يتم تنفيذه
خلال الفتره الاخيره هناك هجمات مكثفه
كانت من قبل المسيرات استهدفت الحدود
الروسيه في عده مناطق كانت هذه المناطق
ايضا قد اعلنت انها لن تقوم باعداد او
احتفالات عيد النصر لتحسبا لحدوث حدوث
هجوم من قبل الجانب الاوكراني ولضمان امن
السكان هناك احمد
المعطيات ايضا
في الايام المقبله خاصه مع اقتراب موعد
الاحتفال بعيد النصر وهذه الاحتفالات التي
يفترض او دائما كما اجره العاده يحضرها
رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بنفسه
احمد كما قال المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الكرملين لن يكون هناك تغيير في خطط
اقامه احتفالات عيد النصر وبالاخص هنا
مشاركه الرئيس الروسي
لا تزال قائمه طبعا بالتاكيد سيكون هناك
تجديد امني كبير هو قد بدا الان قبيل
الاحتفالات دائما تقوم العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو باغلاق جميع الطرق المؤديه الى
الكرملين من اجل الاعداد وبدا التدريب
القوات الروسيه هناك
للاحتفالات قبيله نحو اسبوع من هذه
الاحتفالات يتم اغلاق جميع الطرق المؤديه
الى الساحه الحمراء وبالتالي سيكون هناك
بالطبع تجديد اكبر بعد هذا الحادث وبعد
هذا الاختراق الكبير للعاصمه الروسيه
موسكو طبعا هذه ليست في المره الاولى يتم
استهدافها العاصمه الروسيه من قبل مسيرات
اوكرانيا ولكنها لم تصل الى قلب العاصمه
الروسيه هناك
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو محاطه كما تحدث
اكثر من مره عمده موسكو بانها محصنه
بانظمه الدفاع الجويه اخرها كان قد تم
تركيبه على اسطح المؤسسات من بينها وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ايضا على اسطح المؤسسات
الروسيه هناك انظمه دفاع جويه بحال طبعا
تم اختراق
الجو الروسي او في العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
سيتم طبعا اسقاط اي مسيره تقوم باختراق
المجال الجوي فوق العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
احمد الشارع روسيا ايضا كانت يعني كيف
يتابع ما حدث باي عين وهل رصدت فعل شعبيه
تجاه ما يحدث
حقيقه احمد هو قبيله البدء الاحتفالات
بعيد النصر هناك بالقليل من التخوف طبعا
بسبب الحديث المستمر عن وجود
احتمال بدء القوات الاوكرانيه بهجوم مضاده
على الاراضي الروسيه هناك طبعا كان يتخوف
من قبل السكان الروس حول اولا توقيت بدا
الهجوم وكيفيه تنفيذ هذا الهجوم بالفعل
كان هناك سيكون استهداف
للاراضي الروسيه خلال احتفالات عيد النصر
يوم التاسع من شهر من شهر مايو ولكن طبعا
الشارع روسيا الان يترقب طبعا الرده الفعل
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وعلى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بعد هذا الحادث لان كما تحدثت
لك ان الكريبن قال انه سيقوم بالرد بقوه
وسيتخذ القرار بتوقيت وكيفيه الرد فيما
بعد على هذا الهجوم الذي اخترق المجال
الجوي للعاصمه الروسيه مو سكو احمد وسنكون
معك في متابعه تطورات جديده ونعود اليكم
مره اخرى في سياق هذه الساعه الاخباريه
وهذه التغطيه متى ما توفرت لك معلومات
جديده شكرا لك كافيه ومشاهدينا ننتقل الان
الى موسكو وما على المحلل السياسي الدكتور
رونالد بيجاماف اهلا بك دكتورنا بدايه او
اسم تعليقك على ما جرى اليوم او في الليره
الماضيه في موسكو وتحديث
السلام عليكم ما حدث اليوم هو طبعا يمكن
قراءته في اطار الحرب العالميه من الناحيه
العسكريه لم ياخذوا شيا كبيرا لانه هناك
الهجومات الاوكرانيه الى المرافق والاحداث
العسكريه الروسيا في عمق روسيا ولكن هذه
المره هذا الهجوم سيكون له توفير اعلامي
واثر كبير بلا شك
وسنشهد كيف سترد عليه روسيا لان هذه المره
مع الاستهداف استهداف البريميرن وهو قلب
روسيا واعتقد انه اراد روسي سيكون في
الوقت المناسب وفي المكان المناسب قبل كل
شيء يجب تقويه وتعزيز الدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه وتركيز سهل اهتمام
المسيرات ومكافحه سيارات اما
قررت اعتقد انه اهم شيء اليوم بالنسبه الى
القياده روسيه هو عدم
الانسياق
والقواعد اللغه التي تفرضها
النظام الاوكراني يبدو انه
يسعى الى
الاوضاع في روسيا ولكن لم ياخذوا ذلك
الدكتور قبل الانخراط في مساله النوايا
الاوكرانيه ودورها في هذا العمل لكن هل
تعتقد ان الرئيس بوتين كان هو المقصود
فعلا بهذا الهجوم معنى او الرئاسه الروسيه
كانت تقول بان الرئيس الروسي لم يكن
متواجدا في موقع الهجوم في الليله الماضيه
هذا لا يلعب دورا رئيسيا لانه هو اهم شيء
هو استهداف قلب روسيا استخدام
بنسبه للروس هي هي مش مهم الرئيس موجودنا
بمجرد حقيقه
استخدام
هذا
يفرض ويخلق وضعا جديدا في هذا السرالنا
حتى الان روسيا مثلا لما تضرب
مقر
الحكومه الاوكرانيه
ومطار
وغيرها من الاهداف من مراكز اتخاذ القرار
كما يقال في روسيا اما ناخذ اليوم انا
اوكرانيا تسعى لخلق الواقع الجديد في هذا
الصراعه وربما لاخباط
الخطط الروسيه الخطط الروسيه مبنيه الان
على
[موسيقى]
سؤال وجيه يعني هم يعرفون جيدا ان عيد
الناس بنسبه الى شوب روسيا
وبيلاروسيا وايضا اوكرانيا هي الذاكره
والذاكره قديسه بنسبه الى الروس فلذلك هم
يريدون يريدون استخدام هذه الفرصه
لتصيري سيكولوجيا وناسيا على المعنويات
الشعب الروسي وهذا ايضا يحدث قبيله
هجوم الاوكراني
المرتقب في الجبهه يبدو انها مقدمه لهذا
الهجوم طيب اشرطه حديثك قبل قليل دكتور
لان موسكو لم تبادر الى استهداف
المؤسسات او المراكز الحساسه والهامه
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا كانت كما تحدث عن
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه على سبيل المثال هل
يعني ذلك ان هذه المراكز الان وهذه مؤسسه
الهامه وبما فيها الرئاسه الاوكرانيه باتت
اهداف مشروعه للجانب الروسي
اعتقد روسيا ستتخذ مثل هذه مثل هذا القرار
وهناك الاصوات تعالت في روسيا لاتخاذ مثل
هذه القرارات ولكن انا في اعتقادي الشخصي
روسيا ساتواصل عملياتها العسكريه في
الجبهه هو اولا سيتم تكثيف الضفاد
الجويه ثانيا
الاسترداد للهجوم الاوكراني في
مختلف قطعه الجبهه
الاسترداد
واعتقد انه لا يجب الان اتخاذ قرارات
صاريه جدا
يعني يمكن القول الان انما حدث في ليله
الماضيه يعد بمثابه تحول جوهري في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وسيفتح ذلك الباب امام
تعاطي مختلف مختلف مع الازمه دكتور
رونالدز
سنشهد ذلك قريبا لينال كل حال من الاحوال
هناك
ستكون انا اي طافه
في
في بلا شك لان
الهجوم الاوكرانيا المرتكب قريب ويجب يبدا
في كل حال من الاحوال
وكل
الانظار
تتجه الان نحو نحو الجبهه في اوكرانيا
تفضل معي دكتور رونالدو واساعد اليك من
جديد في سياق هذه التغطيه والامر مشاهدينا
ننتقل الى المحلل السياسي رامي الخليفه
العلي من باريس اهلا بك استاذ رامي معنا
في هذه التغطيه وفي تقديرك يعني هل
اوكراني بحاجه فعلا لهذه الخطوه في هذا
التوقيت لمهاجمه العمق الروسي بهذا الشكل
هل يخدم ذلك المصالح والاهداف الاوكرانيه
اهلا بك تحيه لك ولمشاهدك الكرام لا شك
بان هنالك ضربه معنويه اذا كان اكثر من ان
يكون تاثيرا واقعيا على موازين القوى ما
بين الطرفين لا شك بان تحويل الحرب من
اوكرانيا الى روسيا خصوصا بعد الهجمات
المتواليه التي شهدناها طوال الشهور
الماضيه منذ شهر اكتوبر على وجه التحديد
عندما بدات القوات الروسيه باستهداف البنى
التحتيه في اوكرانيا باستهداف حواضر المدن
وبالتالي بدا الرؤيه يتعاظم رويدا رويدا
في مناطق كانت خارج ساحه المعركه نتحدث عن
شبه جزيره بدايه ثم بدات تدخل بعض الضربات
الى مناطق داخل روسيا الان وهذا الهجوم لا
شك بانه يغير قواعد الاشتراك كما تعلم منذ
البدايه كانت تداخل قوات الروسيه الشرق
عدم استهداف الاراضي الروسيه شرطا اساسيا
لحلف الناتو من اجل تزويد اوكرانيا
بالسلاح لان الحكم الناتو في ذلك التوقيت
لم يكن يريد اي تصعيد مع اجانب روسي وان
يتحول الصراع بشكل مباشر اما وان
فقد انتقل الى داخل الاراضي الروسيه اذا
كانت بالفعل اوكرانيا هي من قامت بهذه
الهجمات فذلك يعني تغيير قواعد الاشتباك
ونتوقف يبدو واثقا يعني تصريحاته من
مسؤوليه اوكرانيا من هذا الهجوم او وراء
هذا الهجوم وقوفها وراء هذا الهجوم تحديدا
طبعا الامر متعلق ايضا بما سوف يصدر من
اوكرانيا لان هذا مهم للغايه اذا ما اكلت
اوكرانيا هذا الهجوم فذلك يعني ان تغييرا
كبيرا في قواعد الاشتباك سوف نشهده خلال
الفتره القادمه وهنالك تصاعد في العنق
وربما استهداف للمراكز الحساسه حتى الان
قصر الرئاسه في كيف والمناطق الحيويه
الاساسيه وسط العاصمه كيف لم تتعرض
للتدمير كما مناطق اخرى في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي يمكن ان نتوقع رده فعل عنيفه من
قبل الجانب الروسي باستخدام صواريخ
المجنحه وصواريخ المتطوره التي يمكن ان
تكون اكثر دقه من الصواريخ التي استخدمت
حتى الان واكثر تدميرا مما استخدمه
وبالتالي باعتقادي ان الجانب الروسي اذا
ما اقتنع بالفعل انه هي المسؤوله بشكل
مباشر ويبدو كما ذكرت بان هذا هو واقع
الحال باعتقادي ان هنالك رده فعل وربما
تسبق ما يدل ما يسمى هجوم الربيع الذي
كانت تقدم اوكرانيا بل بدات عمليا عبر
تمشيط الضفه الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر خلال
الايام الماضيه وبالتالي باعتقادي اننا
نتجه الى مزيد من التدهور على الصعيد
الميداني وعلى الصعيد العسكري واستخدام
لكامل القوه من قبل الجانب الروسي
واستهداف اماكن ربما لم يتم استهدافها حتى
الان بمجمل الاحوال باعتقادي اننا نشهد
مرحله مختلفه من العمليات العسكريه ربما
لم نشهد خلال الفتره الماضيه طيب وهل ترجح
انخراط دول اخرى ايضا في هذه العمليه او
دعا نقل محاوله من اطراف اخرى لتوريط
اوكرانيا في في هذه الازمه من اطراف ترى
مصلحه في تصاعد حده هذه الحرب
متداخله عمليا في الصراع ولكن بشكل غير
مباشر طبعا على راسها حلف الناتو الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي عمليا هي التي تقف
وراء اوكرانيا وهي التي سمحت بصمود
اوكرانيا طوال كل تلك الشهور الماضيه على
امتداد السنه ونيف خلال العمليات العسكريه
التي تشمها روسيا لولا الدعم الامريكي
والدعم الغربي والدعم حلف الناتو لم تكن
اوكرانيا لتصمد الاراده الامريكيه حتى
الان هو بقاء هذا الوضع بقاء هذه هذا
الصراع هذه الحرب لم تكن هنالك اراده
حقيقيه من اجل ايقاف التصعيد وبالتالي
باعتقاد ان هنالك مصلحه في استمرار الصراع
لكن الانخراط المباشر شخصيا استبعد ذلك
لانه ليس من مصلحه حلف الناتو ولولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الدخول في مواجهه
مباشره لان التكلفه ذلك سوف تكون باهظه
وايضا روسيا ليس مصلحتها الدخول في مواجهه
مع حلف الناتو مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لذلك سوف تبقى الحرب على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه طيب تفضل بالبقاء معي
سيدي من جديد في سياق هذه الساعه من
التغطيتنا لهذا الملف
وينتقل الان مشاهدينا الى كييف والصحفي
محمد البابا اهلا بك محمد ما صدر هذه
الاستهدافات وهذا الاستهداف للكريم لينك
في الداخل الاوكراني وكيف يراقب
الاوكرانيون ما حدث هناك
نعم يعني خلال ساعتين او ثلاثه الساعتين
الماضيتين هناك تركب كبير في الشارع
الاوكراني وسائل الاعلام تتحدث عن
الاستهداف الذي حصل للكرملين ليله امس
بمسييرتين وبحسب تسجيلات الفيديو هناك كما
ذكرت في نشره السابقه هناك يعني يتم
الحديث عن احد سيناريوهين السيناريو الاول
وهو التشكيت بصحه هذه العمليه وربما كما
يتهم يعني جزء كبير من الراي العام
الاوكراني يتهم روسيا بافتعال هذه العمليه
خاصه للتشويه ولضرب سمعه اوكرانيا قبل
الهجوم الذي تعد له اوكرانيا هجوم الربيع
والهجوم المضاد الذي تعد له يعد له الجيش
الاوكراني في يعني المناطق التي تشرب
عمليات عسكريه في شرق اوكرانيا لتحرير
الاراضي السيناريو الاخر يتحدث انه ربما
رساله كبيره من الجانب الاوكراني عن تطور
الجيش الاوكراني عن استطاعه المسيرات
الاوكرانيه كسر الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه
والعبور لاكثر من الف كيلو متر والوصول
الى الهدف الاصعب وهو الكريملين خاصه في
الاسبوع الذي يسبق يعني حفل او الاحتفالات
النصر التي تقوم بها روسيا عاده في الساحه
الحمراء والاستعدادات الامنيه ويعتبر خارق
امني كبير يعني هذه العمليه خرج امن كبير
للاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه لوصول مسيرتين
الى القرملين في هذا الوقت الذي تعتبر
يعني اكثر الاوقات تشدد يعني الاجراءات
الامنيه مشدده في موسكو وفي محيطها وايضا
في كامل الاراضي الروسيه لذلك يعني هناك
الراي الاول الاوكراني هو تشكيك بصحه هذه
العمليه وتعتبر من المسرحيات كما وصف احد
الاعلاميين الاوكرانيين في مداخله عبر
قناه
الاوكرانيه وصف انه ربما هذه ضمن
المسرحيات التي تقوم بها موسكو تحضيرا
لعمل ما او استهداف كبير قد تقوم به روسيا
للاراضي الاوكرانيه وقامت بهذه العمليه
لخلق تبرير لاستهداف مستقبلي قد تقوم به
روسيا او
الاجراءات الامنيه على حالها ولكن بحسب
يعني ايضا تواصلنا مع مصادرنا الخاصه في
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تقول ان الجيش
الاوكراني على كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
منذ يعني منذ مساء امس عندما بدات روسيا
باوقامت روسيا بهجوم مسيرات على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه وايضا قبل حوالي ساعه من الان
كان هناك استهداف لمحطه القطارات في خرسون
الجيش الاوكراني وضع بحاله استنفار عام
على كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه تحسبا لاي
عمليه تقوم بها روسيا اتجاه الاراضي
بعض التقارير الاعلاميه تحدثت من قبل عن
ان عدم استهداف روسيا لاي مراكز للرئاسه
الاوكرانيه مثلا اول مراكز المهمه
والحساسه في اوكرانيا ربما ياتي بسبب
تفاهمات بين حكومتين البلدين استهداف هذه
المؤسسات في كل من موسكو
هذه المعلومات محمد يعني بحسب ما نراه
ومنذ بدايه الحرب
حتى الجيش الاوكراني والاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه ابطلت ثلاثه محاولات اغتيال
للرئيس الاوكراني فلادي
وتم استهداف مجموعتين تم يعني استهدافها
والقضاء عليها داخل العاصمه الاوكرانيه في
الايام العشره الاولى التي بدات بها او
الغزو الروسي للاراضي الاوكرانيه ولكن بعد
ذلك اولا لا وجود لاي تواصل بين الجانب
مبارك تواصل مباشره بين السلطات
الاوكرانيه والسلطات الروسيه الجانب
الاوكراني يعتبر ان روسيا هي عدو
لاوكرانيا وان روسيا قد مستعده للقيام باي
عمل
كسرت روسيا الخطوط الحمراء عندما استهدفت
الطاقه الاوكرانيه محطات الطاقه
الاوكرانيه ومحطات التدفئه وعاشه يعني
اكثر من سته مليون اوكراني في برلين في
بدايه فصل الشتاء بعد استهداف محطات
الطاقه ومحطات لذلك لا وجود لاي بحسب
معلوماتنا الخاصه ويعني قراءتنا الخاصه لا
تفاهمات ولا خطوط حمراء بين الطرفين
الجانب الاوكراني يعتبر ان روسيا قد غزت
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وقامت بشرائم حرب
كبيره في محي يعني على بعد عشره كيلو متر
من هنا في منطقه اربيل ومثل منطقه بوتشر
كان هناك جرائم ضد الانسانيه الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي والسلطات
الاوكرانيه وايضا في شرق اوكرانيا فيزيون
كان هناك جرائم حرب ما يعتبر الجانب
الاوكراني ان اي هدف او اي عمليه يقوم بها
ضد روسيا هي رد فعل على الغزو الروسي
للاراضي الاوكرانيه على هذه الحرب التي
وركت ليست وقت روسيا قد غيرت الوضع
الاقتصادي للعالم منذ الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير لذلك كما ذكرنا حتى هذه اللحظه في
اوكرانيا الان حاله ترقب وانتظار لما
ستقوم به ستكون به الساعات القليله
المقبله هل ستكون روسيا برد عسكري كبير او
سيكون الرد في الشرق اوكرانيا حيث هناك
قتال عنيف وايضا الجيش الاوكراني بدا
بالقيام بعمليات داخل بخموت وينتقل من من
الدفاع للهجوم داخل ضخمه وبالامس كان هناك
تقدم واستعاده استعاد الجيش الاوكراني
نقاط مهمه في داخل مدينه ضخمه وتراجعت
مجموعات والقوات الروسيه داخل تلك المدينه
ربما توقيت الاستهداف او ما حصل في الكلام
قد يغير وضع الحرب قد تتخذ وهذا هنا
السؤال ايضا محمد يعني هل هناك من يربط
بين هذا الهجوم على الكريبلين في الليله
الماضيه وما يحدث على الارض في شرق
اوكرانيا
الجانب الاوكراني يربط جميع ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا ومن استهدافات الروسيه ببعضها
يعتبر هناك حرب شامله تقوم بها روسيا ضد
الجانب الاوكراني ولا ننسى يعني الاعلان
الذي حصل اعلنته موسكو بتفكيك شبكات شبكه
واتهمت اوكرانيا يعني تجهيز شبكه للقيام
باعمال عدائيه في روسيا الجانب الاوكراني
وبحسب يعني استخبارات الاوكرانيه نفت
تماما علاقتها باي شبكات داخل موسكو ونفى
الجانب الاوكراني نفيا تاما ان يكون قد
ارسل يعني معاونين او ارسل اشخاص للقيام
بعمليات ارهابيه قد تستهدف الدخل الروسي
هذا الموقف يعني الجور او الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن
حتى هذه اللحظه موقف رسمي اوكرانيا حول
استهداف لا يوجد حتى ان التغريدك الرئيس
الاوكراني التي يعني ربطت بعض وسائل
الاعلام انه ربما تغريدته هي ترتبط بهذه
العمليه بحسب معلوماتنا هذه التغريده كانت
ضمن الحديث الذي يقوم به الرئيس الاوكراني
الان في فنلندا حول حزمه عقوبات جديده
تاخذها اوكرانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي حول
روسيا يعني تشديد الضغط على روسيا حتى
تكون روسيا بسحب جنودها وعساكرها وجيشها
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه والجلوس على طاوله
لانهاء هذه المعارف او لهذه الحرب محمد
تفضل البقاء معي ساعود اليك من جديد وشكرا
لك على كل هذه المعلومات مشاهدينا ننتقل
الان الى موسكو والكاتب السياسي بسام
البودي اهلا بك بسام بدايه ما هي قراءتك
لهذا الهجوم وتداعيات المستقبل ايضا على
تطورات
الميدانيه والسياسيه ايضا بين البلدين
نتحدث عن روسيا واوكرانيا
استاذ احمد يسعد مساك يعني انا بعتقد انه
طالما اوكرانيا سعت لادخال الناتو بحرب
مباشره مع روسيا وبدفع من بولندا
وبريطانيا ولذلك انا اعتقد ان هذا الهجوم
على الكرملين كان توقيته ليس عبثا فوجود
الرئيس الاوكراني في فنلندا يعني وفنلندا
التي دخلت الى الناتو ليس ببعيد كانت بسبب
ان اوكرانيا ارادت استفزاز روسيا من اجل
ان تقوم بعمل ما ربما استهدافي على
الاراضي الفنلنديه من اجل ادخال الناتو
بحرب مباشره مع روسيا هذه نقطه النقطه
الاخرى ربما تكون هذه العمليه هي عمليه من
اجل اضعاف الشعور الوطني الروسي ومن اجل
رفع معنويات الجيش الاوكراني عشيه الهجوم
المضاد المزعوم الذي تحدث زعيم فاجنر عن
انه قد بدا بالفعل وقد قلت انا قبل قليل
على قناتكم الكريمه ان يعني الرد الروسي
سيكون على مركز اقامه وقد وافقني على ذلك
فلوط رئيس البرلمان الروسي حين قال انه
يعني ان الاوان لقصف مقر اقامه يعني ايضا
افهم من ذلك
بسام انك لا تستبعد انخراط دول اخرى ربما
وطرف اخرى في
الواقيعه ربما في بين موسكو في هذا
التوقيت بكل تاكيد انا لا استبعد لان اي
مسيره تريد ان يكون لها
معلومات استخباراتيه من الجي بي اس ومن
الاقمار الصناعيه الاستخباراتيه العسكريه
اذا كانت هذه المسيره جاءت من اوكرانيا
الى موسكو لا تستطيع السير وحدها دون دعم
لوجستي معلوماتي من قبل الاقمار الصناعيه
وهذه الاقمار الصناعيه هي اقمار الغربيه
امريكيه او بريطانيه او غيرها اضف الى ذلك
انه اذا كانت هذه المسيره قد خرجت من داخل
روسيا وليس من اوكرانيا يعني هناك
من هو مجند لصالح المخابرات
الاوكرانيه وقام بالعمل هذا الارهابي من
داخل الاراضي الروسيه فالمصيبه اكبر ولكن
اعلان يعني محافظ موسكو الحاكم موسكو عن
منع تسير يعني منع المسيرات فوق السماء
موسكو هذا سيعطي روسيا وموسكو الامكانيه
برصد اي عمليات تخريبيه ربما يقوم بها
احدهم لغسل هذه الجينات واستهدافي والقاء
القبض عليه اما غير ذلك فاعتقد ان هناك
يعني تجديد يجب ان يكون من قبل القوات
الدفاع الجوي الروسي ضمن موسكو من اجل
يعني الغاء اي عمليه ناجحه قد تقوم بها
القوات الاوكرانيه اثناء الاحتفالات
باعياد مايو الحرب الوطنيه العظمى لكن
الاحوال سيد بسام يعني هذا الهجوم على
الكلام وفي هذا التوقيت يكشف بالتاكيد عن
اختراق وخلل امني ربما في المنظومه
الامنيه في روسيا وهذا يتطلب من موسكو
ربما مراجعه حساباتها الامنيه مره اخرى
خاصه انها في مرحله
التعاطي او الحرب مع كييف وليس مع منظومه
النيتو كامله من ناحيه نعم ومن ناحيه اخرى
فمن ناحيه نعم لانها مهتم الاختراق فعلا
ووصول الدرونات الى يعني سقف التعبير على
بعد امتار من القبه ولكن من ناحيه اخرى لا
يمكن لاي قوه دفاعيه في العالم ان تحصر
موضوع الدرونات المسيره الصغيره التي ممكن
ان تطلقها على بعد كم واحد من الكريملين
يعني هناك في موس عديده للاستخدامات
للسلميه المتعدده ممكن تحميلها بقنابل
وارسالها على بعد كيلومتر يعني لا يمكن
لاي دوله في العالم
ان ترصد كل الاجواء وكل المناطق وبالذات
ان روسيا مساحتها كبيره موسكو كبيره
للغايه يعني تتخيل مساحه موسكو يعني
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بقدرها وعزتها
تم يعني استهدافها في 11 سبتمبر في العمل
الارهابي الذي استهدفون
[موسيقى]
برج التجاره العالمي يعني لا يمكن لاي
دوله مهما على شانها من الوقوف في وجه
المجموعات الارهابيه التي تقيم على
اراضيها سواء من مواطنيها او من مواطنين
دخلاء يعني هذا الموضوع واضح لاي شخص كان
طيب التزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه النوعيه هي
من العوامل التي تزيد حجه التوتر بين
روسيا والغرب هل ستزيد روسيا من قائمه
خياراتها للتعامل مع الملف المؤرق لبوسكو
يعني انا اعتقد انه اذا استمر الغرب
بتعاملته وتزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه وخصوصا
الحديث عن القذائف تصل مداها الى 300 كيلو
متر واليوم استهداف الكريم بهذه الطائرات
المسيره التي تحدثت قبل قليل وقلت انه لا
يمكن وصولها الى
مقاطعتك فقد يسمح لي بالشر هذا خبر عاجل
مجلس الدوم الروسيه يقول حان الوقت لاطلاق
هجوم صاروخي على مقر اقامه ازيلنسكي يمكنك
التعليق على هذا الخبر بسام بعد ان تكمل
فكرتك نعم تفضل انا قلت لك قليل ان فالودن
قال انه يعانى الاوان يعني استهداف مقال
اقامه وهذا يعني اننا نحن امام عمليه
تصعيد وتصعيد مضاد اذا ما استمر الغرب عن
جهيته وتزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه بعيده
المدى وخصوصا بعد الاستهداف الذي تم الليل
الماضي على الكريملين يعني ان الناتو قرر
حرب معروفه يعني ما بقي من ما بقي مكان
يستهدفوه يعني اذا تم استهداف الكريميوم
هل تبقى روسيا متفرجه لا اعتقد ان روسيا
ستبقى متفرجه وفي البدايه سترسل صواريخها
الدقيقه للحدود الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
البولنديه وربما تضرب اهداف او تعلن ان اي
مكان لتجميع الاسلحه التي تقدم لاوكرانيا
خارج حدود اوكرانيا هي اهداف مشروعه
لروسيا لون الغرب لا يستحي ويدخل المعركه
بشكل مباشر فيما يتعلق بما اشرت اليه من
امتداد الغرب اللي الاسلحه هناك شروط طبعا
معروفه بان هذه الاسلحه يجب ان لا تصل الى
عمق الروسي يعني هل المثل الذي نفهم من
ذلك يعني هل فقدت السيطره مثلا على كييف
ام هذه
الخطوه هي بتنفيذ اوكراني بحت دون تدخل من
الغرب يبدو ان اوكرانيا تريد توريط الغرب
في حرب مباشره مع روسيا الكون الغربي
دائما يصرح انه لا يريد حرب مباشره مع
روسيا وروسيا تقول لا اريد حرب مباشره مع
الناتو ولكن اوكرانيا يعني حبل النجاه لها
هو دخول الناتو الى المعركه بشكل مباشر
على الاقل دخوله تحت علم مزيف يعني كما
نجد القوات البولنديه تحارب الى جانب
اوكرانيا على الخطوط الجبهات ونسمع اللهجه
الهولنديه في كل الفيديوهات التي يتم
نشرها من قبل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه نجد ان
يعني
اوكرانيا لا تكتفي بهذا الامر تريد ان
يدخل قوات امريكيه وغيرها تحتها ولا على
الاقل تقدير تحت علم مزيف ولكن روسيا
تراقب
تمارس سياسه القضم البطيء للاراضي طيب
من جديد
طيب نحن
الان معي السيد محمد العروقي من كييف مدير
تحرير موقع اوكرانيا اليوم سيد محمد كيف
تتابع ما يجري من احداث ما هي رد الفعل
التي رصدتها ايضا في الداخل الاكرون
الاوكراني اذا ام حدث في الليله الماضيه
في الكرمين
تحياتي لكم الاستاذ المشاهدين وضيفكم من
موسكو يعني حقيقه يعني الناطق باسم الرئيس
الاوكراني نفى تماما علم اوكرانيا بهذا
الموضوع وان اوكرانيا تسعى لتحرير اراضيها
وليس لطيار شخصيات ولكن علينا ان هناك
امرين يعني هناك امر العاطفه وامر العقل
اللي تحدثنا بالعاطفه بين معارض سنتهم
اوكرانيا ولكن اذا تحدثنا بالعقل مع هدف
اوكرانيا من ذلك ويعني اغتيال الرؤساء
والزعماء والمشهورين لا يتم بهذه الطريقه
بقصف يعني في وضع الليل او النهار امام
المراه الجميع فبالتالي اعتقد ان الموضوع
يعني استبعد اوكرانيا من الموضوع ولكن
علينا الاطلاع الى امر اهم من هذا وذات
محمد اعذرني لكن تعليقه على هذه النقطه
الهي يعني بعض الضيوف الذين كانوا معي في
الساعه في الساعه الماضيه يعني اشار الى
ان هذه الخطوه تحمل رمزيه كبيره لكسر اذا
اراده الروس خاصه وانها تاتي قبل ايام من
احتفالات الروس بعيد النصر وهو معروف مدار
رمزيه واهميه هذا اليوم بنسبه لهم
يعني دعوكم فقط هذه ارد عليك الان سافرت
الاصدار تدوي بالعاصمه كيف الان في هذه
اللحظه يعني بدات سافرت من هجوم رؤوس
الصاروخ هو الشيك على المدنيين والامنيين
في العاصمه يعني اولا الانتصارات التي
تحتفل بها روسيا هذه ليست انتصارات روسيا
هذه يعني انتصارات الدول الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق والحلفاء والنصر يعني اذا كان
لروسيا فهو ايضا لاوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
فبالتالي اعتقد هذا الامر مستبعد اعتقد ان
كل التحاليل تقول ان اوكرانيا على وشك
هجوم مضاد ان الجيش الاوكراني الروسي اصبح
في شكل دفاعي وليس هجومي ان روسيا في ورطه
لا تستطيع ادفعل شيء امام هذا الهجوم ان
الروس تورط في محمود ان الجيش
الاوكراني
ان جزيره القلم بها احداث عسكريه فتريد
روسيا ايجاد مبرر لمزيد من القصف الوحشي
للاراضي الاوكرانيه
وقصف امور اخرى غير مصادر ومنشات الطاقه
في اوكرانيا قد تلجا الى قصف مقرات سياديه
ورئاسيه ومنشات
وغير ذلك فبالتالي هناك هذا هذه وجهه
النظر التي انا يعني اؤمن بها لان هذا
الموضوع يعني كيف دوله عظمى بحجم روسيا
والكريم والصحه الحمراء عندما نسمع بها
بهذه الدوله العظمى تستطيع ان تصل اليها
بكل سهوله هذه الطائرات المسيره يعني هذا
السؤال يعني اطرحه على الراي العام
للاجابه عليه وما هي التكنولوجيا التي
تمتلكها اوكرانيا للوصول الى مثل ذلك في
في عدم يعني جاهزيه وفعاليه المضادات
التكنولوجيه التي امس قالوا ان لديهم
تكنولوجيا من الجيل الخامس لرصد هذه
المضادات اللي رد هذه الطائرات فكيف يمكن
تحقيق ذلك واعتقد ان الغرب لا يجرا ايضا
على التورط بمثل هذه الامور ان هذا تعني
حرب عالميه ثالثه يعني انت تتفق مع
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه التي تقول
محادثه ولكن سيد محمد يعني ما الذي ستفيده
روسيا من ذلك هل انت اشرت الى انها ترغب
ربما في قصف في زياده وتيره القصف في
اوكرانيا لكنها تقصف المدن الروسيه بشده
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب يعني ما الجديد الذي
سيضيفه ذلك انا سا الجديد روسيا كما قلت
الان على ابواب هجوم مضاد اوكراني وشير
فبالتالي تبحث عن مبرر لاستخدام قوه اكثر
لصد هذا اليوم لانها لا تعلم موعده ومتى
واليته وكيف سيكون هذا الهجوم روسيا في
حيرم الامراض في استنزاف وارهاق نفسي
ومعنويات الجلود والجيش والقياد تترقب
الان هي في وضع الترقب وهذا الترقب ايضا
له خسائره الكبيره في معنويات جنودي
فبالتالي تريد ان تبادل بفعل ما قد يعني
قد يوقف هذا الهجوم طيب اعطيني من جديد في
سياق هذه الاخباريه وننتقل مشاهدينا الى
محمد البابا زميل الصحفي محمد
مجد لديك
نعم يعني قبل دقائق دوره سفارات الانذار
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف ومنطقه
كييفسومي وعدد من المدن الاوكرانيه تحسبا
وما يتداول في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
انه ربما قد تكون وخاصه في تيليجرام انه
ربما سيكون هناك ضربات صاروخيه تستهدف
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ردا او كردد فعل روسيه على ما حصل حتى هذه
اللحظه هناك استنفار عام في المدن
الاوكرانيه معظم المدن الاوكرانيه هناك
دعوات واندريه قبل حوالي دقيقتين عبر شبكه
تيليجرام وهو مدير المكتب الرئاسي دعا
المواطنين بالدخول الى الملاجئ فورا بعد
اطلاق صفارات الانذار في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه ومقاطعه اياب وايضا مقاطعه
مقاطعتي تشرني
وعدد من المدن الاوكرانيه والمقاطعات
الاوكرانيه تحسبا كما ذكرت تحسبا لضربات
صاروخيه قد تقوم بها يقوم بها القوات
الروسيه والجيش الروسي وموسكو للاراضي
الاوكرانيه كرده فعل على ما حصل في الكريم
خاصه انها ليله امس ايضا عاشت المدن
الاوكرانيه وخاصه العاصمه الاوكرانيه حاله
من التراكم واصوات الانفجارات كانت تدوي
في سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف بعدما
قامت الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه باستهداف
اكثر من ثماني عشره مسيره فوق سماء مقاطعه
والعاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف حتى هذه اللحظه
حذر جوي بدات يعني حتى الحركه في الطرقات
تخص قليلا بعد اطلاق سفارات الانذار في
العاصمه الوطنيه يعني هل يتجاوب
الاوكرانيون مع هذه هي المناشدات بالدخول
الملاجئ هل تاثرت الحياه اليوميه بشكل
كبير اليوم محمد منبيدات هذا الهجوم
يعني كان قبل حوالي ساعتين بعد يخف الى حد
ما خاصه في وسط العاصمه كيف حركه يعني
الحركه الطبيعيه والان بعد اطلاق سفارات
حتى في الطريق المقابل كان هناك يعني
الان بدات تخف حركه يعني المرور حتى ان
بعض المحال التجاريه يعني هناك مصرف وعاده
عندما يكون هناك انذار جوي تقوم بعض
المؤسسات باقفال يعني المكاتب والمحل
وتوجه ودعوه الموظفين والسكان للتوجه الى
يعني الملاجئ في تلك المنطقه
هنا هي منطقه سكنيه معظم هناك دعوات عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للمواطنين بعدم
تجاهل الانذار الجوي والدخول باسرع وقت
الى المتاجر يعني انت اشرت الى ان هذا
الاطلاق هذه الصفاره الانذار هو تحسبا لاي
هجوم روسي مضاد لكن يعني هل حدث في التيار
السابقه ان تطلق سفاره الانذار ولا يكون
هناك اي هجوم فعلي يعني بمعنى انه فقط
الاحتياط ليس اكثر
يعني في حالتين عندما يكون هناك ليه
استهداف صاروخي او عندما تقلع مقاتلات في
فوق السماء الروسيه مقاتلات من نوع 31
تحمل صواريخ يعني فرديه الصوت وهي صواريخ
كينجال عندما يتم يعني اقلاع هذه الطائرات
فورا في كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه يعني
تدوي صفارات الانذار تخوفا ان تقوم هذه
الطائرات باطلاق صواريخ التي تعتبر صواريخ
يعني اسرع من من الصوت وتستطيع استهداف
يعني الاماكن الاوكرانيه بسرعه فائقه لذلك
تحسبا لاي عمليه يعني تطلق سفارات الانذار
ولكن في كثير من الاحيان عندما تطلق او
تطير او تقلع طائرات ميج 31 تكون لفتره
ساعه الى ساعه ونصف ولا يكون هناك استهداف
في الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا خلق نوع من
تجاهل من السكان لعمليه يعني الانذار
الجوي ولكن عندما يكون الانذار الجوي ويتم
كتابه عبر خاصه عبر شبكه تيليجرام يعني في
هذه اللحظه في الداخل العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف تم تشغيل العاديه واطفاء صفارات يعني
ارى على شاشه هاتفي انه تم اقفال سفره او
يعني اطفاء الحاله الانذار الجوي
وتوقف سفارات الانذار في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
معي وساعود اليك في سياق هذه نشرح على ما
توفر لك اي جديد نعود مره اخرى مشاهدينا
الى ضيفنا بسام البنيه الكاتب السياسي
موسكو السيد بسام ايضا اطلاق سفاره
الانذار في كييف ومدن اخرى ما دلالات هذه
الخطوه في هذا التوقيت هل تتوقعت او هل
تتوقع ان يكون الرد الروسي بهذه السرعه لا
اعتقد ان روسيا سترد بهذه السرعه روسيا
دائما
ترد وتعرف اين تضرب واين تستهدف وماذا
ستستهدف اما بهذه السرعه لا اعتقد فهذه
الصفارات يبدو انها خلبيه بعد
ربما تكون ليلا الهجمات الصاروخيه ربما
تكون غدا ممكن ان ترد روسيا بطريقه اخرى
جديده مبتك
تستخدمها من قبل اني لست خبيرا عسكريا
ولكن اعتقد ان
كيف ستشعر
بحماوه الموقف وبحراره الرد الروسي هل
سيختصر رد الروسي على على الجانب
الاوكراني فقط ام سيتسع ربما ليشمل اطرافا
اخرى في تقديرك يعني اعتقد ان الرد سيكون
على على الجانب الاوكراني فقط ولكن ربما
تكون هناك اهداف على الحدود الملاصقه
لبولندا وقد يكون هناك تصريح من الكرملين
يتحدث او من وزاره الدفاع عن تهديد او
انذار نهائي
للتدخلات الغربيه في الازمه الاوكرانيه
لاماره تسببه من استهداف للكرملين بنتيجه
عدم المحاسبه وعدم يعني ال ال الصياع
للرغبه الروسيه في احياديه اوكرانيا
ودعمها بالسلاح اذا ما خرجت او انذار اخير
من قبل القوات الروسيه ولم يلتزم الغرب او
تلتزم اوكرانيا ربما نشهد يعني بدايه قصف
لمواقع تجمع القوات حتى خارج اوكرانيا
يعني مثل هذه العمليه التي طالت الكريم
ليله امس يعني هل في تقديرك اطلقت رصاصه
الرحمه على اي فرص لتسويه الازمه والجلوس
ايضا على طاوله المفاوضات وهو ما كانت
طالبه اطراف عده نتحدث عن الصين نتحدث عن
السعوديه عن الامم المتحده يعني انا لا
اعتقد ان هذه العمليه العسكريه او العمليه
الارهابيه التي تمت على لها علاقه بموضوع
المفاوضات موضوع المفاوضات شيء وهذه
العمليه شيء اخر المفاوضات روسيا دائما
جاهزه للمفاوضات بحيث تحقق شروطها وما
هدفته من العمليه العسكريه من خلال
الدبلوماسيه واعطت الصين والسعوديه الضوء
الاخضر في القيام بهذه العمليه التفاوضيه
ولكن كيف غير مستعده للتفاوض وهي تضع شروط
تعجيزيه ليس
برايها يعني يفرض عليها الغرب
من اجل استمراريه الحرب واستنزاف روسيا
فكلنا نذكر يعني عندما تقدمت كيف بورقه
تسويه سلميه دبلوماسيه اثناء مفاوضات
اسطنبول
وقد وافقت روسيا بشكل مبدئي على هذه
الورقه جاء برج جنس وقتها الى كيف وقال
لهم لا يعني نحن نرى ان يجب عليكم ان
تقاتلوا وانسحبوا من هذه الورقه وتنصلوا
منها وتركوها وايضا عندما جاء وزير الدفاع
الامريكي قال لهم عليكم الحرب لان الوقت
غير مناسب للسلام ايضا موضوع الحرب
والسلام ليس بيدي كيف ولذلك روسيا لا تمنع
اي محاولات للتسويه السلميه وهي مع
التسويه السلميه وهذه العمليه لن تؤثر على
التسويه السلبيه اذا ما حقق هذه التسويه
السلميه اهداف العمليه العسكريه بدون حرب
هذا كل ما في الامر اما ان نقول ان عمليه
مثل هذه ستمنع العمليه السينيه لا اعتقد
ذلك لان رجل معتذل وهو يعني يفكر بمصلحه
البلد قبل ان نفكر بشيء اخر وما استهداف
هذه الليله الا بسبب احترام الحكومه
الروسيه للقوانين والدستور الروسي بعدم
منع الحريات والعيش بسلام والشعب يعيش ليس
في حاله حرب يعني فوالا كانوا منعوا يعني
من الاستخدام المدني منذ زمن يعني لم
ينتظروا حتى يتم استهداف الكرملين لاصلاح
ليخرج علينا
عمده موسكو يقول منعنا استخدام اعتبارا من
اليوم اضف الى ذلك ان الحركه الحركه
النزوح الاوكرانيه الى الداخل الروسي
مفتوحه ويعطوهم الجنسيات ويستقبلوهم كاخوه
ومن ضمن هؤلاء يعني هناك العديد ممن
جندتهم المخابرات الاوكرانيه وارسلتهم على
شكل لاجئين او ناجحين الى روسيا وقد
استقبلتهم روسيا بكل يعني حراره وهذا
الموضوع هو المعضله التي يعني تواجهها
روسيا روسيا عليها اعلام الحرب اذا ما
اعلنت الحرب عندها تختلف التعاطي مع العمل
العمل العسكري نقطه النقطه الاخرى التعامل
مع الداخل الروسي وهناك اسواق في روسيا
عديده بدات تتصاعد يعني خصوصا بعد هذه
الازمه يعني هناك غليان في الشارع الروسي
لماذا لا تعلنون الحرب على اوكرانيا وعلى
الناتو وايضا يعني هناك اصوات صقور ورؤوس
حاميه هنا في روسيا تريد الحرب والانتهاء
من المشكله بينما القيامه الذي يؤخر
الرئيس بوتين من اتخاذ هذه الخطوه في
تقديرك يعني انا اعتقد ان الرئيس بوتين
ينظر يعني هو لاعب جوده ويستخدم قوه
الخصوم
ضدها يعني يستخدم قوه خصم ضد المهاجم فنجد
الانهيارات الاقتصاديه التي تحدث في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وافلاس البنوك
نجد الخلاف بين
اعضاء الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي ونجد هناك
ازمه اقتصاديه يعني خانقه ربما ستؤدي الى
كاسات كبير او اكبر الكاسات كبير الذي حدث
في بدايه القرن التاسع عشر في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي ستنهار العمله
الامريكيه وستنهار القوه الضاربه التي
تدعم كيف وسيتخلون عن كيف نعالجنا اضف الى
ذلك هناك انتخابات
قادمه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وغيرها من الدول التي بدات تتصاحب بها
الاصوات التي ضد الدعم الغير مشروطي
اوكرانيا وضد الدعم الغير
يعني
محدد لاوكرانيا هذا يعني ان روسيا باعتقاد
الشخصي تنتظر ان يتخلل الغرب بنفسه عن
اوكرانيا دون الدخول في نزاع عسكري مباشره
مع الناتو لان هذا الحرب ان حدثت ستكون
الحرب الاخيره على هذه الارض وسيكون
الخاسر هو الجميع لان روسيا لا يمكن لها
ان تدمر العالم وتبقى هي دون
ان تتاثر يعني كل العالم ولذلك هناك يعني
حكمه روسيه
[موسيقى]
الاهداف المعلنه من العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا ستوافق روسيا على
المفاوضات وليس لديها اي مشكله يعني كلام
بلوط عندما يقول بوتين انه لا مفاوضات مع
زيلينسكي عندها انا اقول لك ان هناك لاعب
فوضى لان القرار الاول والاخير هنا في
روسيا اليوم للرئيس بوتين لا يوجد اي قرار
لا بالحرب ولا بالسلم الا بيد القائد
الاعلى القوات المسلحه الروسيه لا ديمر
بلاديمر هل سيكتفي المجتمع الدولي في
تقديرك بالروايه الروسيه ام ان تم تداعن
ربما لاجراء تحقيق شفاف ومحايد يمكن ان
يحدد الجهه المسؤوله عن هذا الهجوم بشكل
موضوعي ربما ربما يقوم الغرب بدعوه
لاجراء تحقيق محايد من اجل التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه الروسيه ولكن اعتقد ان
روسيا لن تسمح لاحد لا بالتدخل ولا
بالتحقيق وهي ستحقق وهي ستعلن النتائج ولم
تس عن اي راي اخر غير رايها
المتحده يعني لا يمكن التعويل عليها في
دوره تلعبه مع هذه الازمه من التمدد بشكل
لا يحمد عقبه وايضا فيما يتعلق بالتحقيق
المحايد في هذه الازمه في هذا الحادث
الاخير عفوا
حتى تقوم بالتحقيق المحايد يعني الامم
المتحده اتخذت قرارات عده ولم يلتزم بها
احد واتخذت تقاريرها لا ياخذ بها الارض
ولا الشرق يعني الامم المتحده امم متهالكه
للاسف الشديد
طيب بكين بثقه واحترام الطرفين وايضا كانت
لها محاولات جاده لتقريب وجهات النظر بين
روسيا واوكرانيا هل يمكن ايضا ان تلعب
دورا في تخفيف عده التوتر الان بعدما حدث
يعني
هناك توتر كبير حدث يعني ربما ستكون هناك
ضربه انتقاميه لروسيا وربما تكون هناك
توسيع للاهداف المشروعه لروسيا ولكن الحرب
قائمه قائمه يعني اما عن موضوع الدور
الصيني في حلحله الازمه الاوكرانيه فهذا
امر موجود وهذا امر مرحب بهم من روسيا ومن
كل الدول العالم فدول العالم لا تريد ان
يكون هناك حروب يعني لا في منطقه الخليج
ولا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ولا في اوروبا
ولا في امريكا اللاتينيه ولا في افريقيا
يعني كل العالم تعب من الازم الاقتصاديه
الخانقه الغذاء الى اخره يجب ان يجدوا حلا
لهذه الازمه وروسيا ترحب بهذا الحل ولكن
ليس على حساب امنها وعلى حساب نعم حدودها
نعم شكرا لك ايضا
البني ومشاهدينا نتابع ايضا هذا الخبر
العاجل رئيس البرلمان الروسي يقول سنطالب
القياده باستخدام اسلحه قادره على تدمير
نظام
معنا السيد محمد العروقي من اوكرانيا مره
اخرى محمد اضافه الى ما هذا خبر عاجله
الذي قراته قبل قليل هناك ايضا خبر عاجل
نقل عن رئيس البرلمان الروسي يقول لا يمكن
التفاوض مع زيلينسكي بعدما حدث كيف تعلق
على هذين التصريحين من رئيس البرلمان
الروسي
يعني بدايه سافرت الانذار عادت من جديد في
العاصمه قبل دقيقه من الان تنذر بعباره
جويه قد تكون او لا قد لا تكون يعني نريد
ان نستذكر قبل التعليق هذا المسؤوله عن
الانتخاب في 2019 يعني استشهد العالم كله
بلقاء الرئيس بوتين والتفاوض معه على
مستقبل منطقه الدنباص والسلام بين البلدين
ولكن الرئيس بوتين لم يتفاوض ولم يوافق
على لقاء الرئيسي وقبل ان تحدث هذه الحرب
في في ديسمبر
2021 يعني كل العالم ذهب الى الرئيس
بوتفلي وكان يضع طاوله طوله سته امطار
اللقاء الجميع الان الان يعني وقع في في
يعني في الفخ ويريد الان يعني لا يريد ان
يتفاوض فقد الامل وهو من اعلن في البدايه
او بعد المحادثات او بعد مذبحه التي
ارتكبها الجيش الاوكراني في تقوم العاصمه
كيف اعلم انه لن يتفاوض مع هذا الرئيس
مدام هو الرئيس لروسيا ويمكن التفاوض مع
شخصيات اخرى يعني هذا لا
نعم يعني للتعديل فقط يعني استسمحلي روسيا
احتلت مناطق كبيره من الشرق الاوكراني هذه
النقطه الاولى الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد في
سبتمبر الماضي استطاع ارجاع 48% من هذه
الاراضي التي
احتلالها والهجوم الاوكراني الوشيخ قد
يستطيع ان يحرر لاقول جميع الاراضي ايضا
نسبه كبيره من هذه الاراضي فنحن بحاله حرب
كرر وفرق فبالتالي علينا ان لا نعظم
الامور وننتظر رد يعني روسي استثنائي على
الهجوم على مسرحيه الهجوم على الكريم لان
اوكرانيا غير المسؤوله عن هذا الهجوم الا
مهما هاجمت لدى الاوكران الان من المضادات
الجويه ومن الامكانيات لصد اي هجوم على
اراضيها اوكرانيا الان بعد بعد في نهايه
الحرب او في هذه المرحله اقوى من مرحله
بدايه الحرب على عكس ما يحدث في دول
العالم عندما تكون البدايه قويه والنهايه
ضعيفه لا الان اوكرانيا استفادت من الدعم
استفادت من خبره الحرب ولديها اسلحه
سوفيتيه قديمه طورتها ولديها اسلحه غربيه
فب التالي اعتقد اننا امام معركه في
المستقبل
محترمه سيد محمد لكن يعني هذا ايضا يتنافى
مع التسريبات الامريكيه الوثائق التي سربت
وهي تتحدث عن الجيش الاوكراني وتصفه بانه
الان في حاله يرثى لها كيف تعلق على ذلك
يعني كما ذكرت انا بكل التحليلات
والموثائق والتسريبات ما يعني لما يحدث
على الارض ما يعني لما يحصل على الارض ان
الجيش الاوكراني تقدم الاسبوع الماضي
الشرط نهر دنيبر في منطقه خرسون في مناطق
تحتل روسيا ما يعنينا على الارض ان بخموت
صامد منذ اكثر من عشره اشهر وهي عباره عن
42 كيلو متر مربع بلده هذه في الحروب
الكبيره تؤخذ على الطريق يعني لا يتم
الدخول اليها لا تستطيع
ان كل الصواريخ الروسيه التي تتم القصف
بها من صواريخ كانجال وكروز وغيره تسقط
معظمها فبالتالي التحليلات واجتهاد
المحللين والكتاب والاراء لا اكترث بهم ما
يعنيني ما يحدث على الارض اوكرانيا صامته
خرجت من الشتاء والطاقه الكهربائيه تعمل
بل صدرت الى بولندا والى المجر والى الشهر
الماضي كهرباء فبالتالي الواقع شيء وما
نسمعه في اروقه المحللين والخياليين دعني
اقول اسف على التعبير شيء اخر
تداعيات هذه المحاوله محاوله اغتيال بوتين
كما يقول الروس واول هجوم على هل يمكن ان
تؤدي الى ما لا يحمد عقبه كنزلاق نيته في
هذا الصراع
يعني حقيقه لن يعني لن ينزلق الغرب يعني
يعرف الخطوط الحمراء الغرب جيدا وليس
الدفاع عن الغرب ولا احب الغرب ولكن الغرب
لن يتورط في اي عمليه قد تؤدي الى اندلاع
حرب عالميه ثالثه او تؤدي الى ما لا يحمد
عقبه اعتقد الرد الفعل الروسي ماذا سيكون
هذه الليله او غدا الهجمه الصاروخيه كبيره
سيتم اسقاط معظم هذه الصواريخ وسنصحف في
الصباح الى اعمالنا والحياه سوف تستمر
يعني اذا كان لن يتورط في حرب عالميه مع
روسيا لكن هل سيكتفي باستخدام اوكرانيا في
محاربه روسيا كما يقول الروس ذلك
يعني هم الرز ده هم يقولون ما يقولون
اوكرانيا مستعد ان تتلقى المساعده من اي
طرف يساعدها في تحرير اراضيها الى الحدود
المعترف بها دوليا عام 1991 روسيا تستطيع
صنع السلام في اي لحظه بالانسحاب من تلك
الاراضي والتفاوض لروسيا حقوق لحفظ امنها
لانها الداخل وامنها القومي هذا حقها يمكن
عن طريق المفاوضات التفاوض مع الجهه
الاوكرانيه يا سيدي ان اقول شيئا واحدا
لماذا الغرب استطاع كسب اوكرانيا ولم
تستطع روسيا
ابقاء اوكرانيا في مضمارها لماذا على
روسيا ان تعمل بالاسباب هذه من اجل اعاده
تصليح تلك العلاقات الامر يعني يعتمد على
روسيا ليله تدعي نفسها دوله عظمى وتدعي ان
الشعب الاوكراني الشعب الشقيق كيف يهرب
شعب شقيق من شعب اخر انت لا تعلم سيدي
الفاضل كم حاله الكراهيه التي اصبحت في
الشارع الاوكراني لروسيا ليس فقط بسبب
الدعايه الامريكيه وحب في امريكا وفي
الغرب بسبب التعامل الروسي على روسيا
تغيير مفهومها للتعامل مع الدوله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات